welcome everyone this screencast kicks
off our series on presenting your
research we're going to try to cover the
full life cycle of a project in the
field from work you do for a course like
this on up to the day when you might be
on stage at a top Workshop or conference
giving a talk about your research
let's dive in I just wanted to start
with some practical notes about your
papers for this course
here are some links you might find
useful the links go to the website as
well as to the projects page in the
course code repository I think I would
single out that projects page as
potentially especially useful it's got
FAQs about projects it's got advice
about the individual project components
as well as advice about publishing in
the field in general and also I'm proud
to say it now has an extensive list of
published papers that began their lives
as work for this course I'm really proud
of that list and I hope you find it
inspiring to check that work out
this is a reminder about our overall
perspective on Project work for this
course I talked about this at length in
our methods and metrics screencast but I
think it Bears repeating because it is
so fundamental we will never evaluate a
project for this course based on how
good the results are we recognize that
there is a bias towards so-called
positive results in the scientific
literature in general and a bias away
from so-called negative results
I think that's unfortunate that bias I
feel like we're making progress as a
scientific community in terms of getting
people to Value negative results but it
will be a long journey
for this course though we're freed from
all of those biases we're not subject to
any of the constraints that would
motivate that and so we can do the right
and good thing of valuing positive
results negative results and everything
in between
fundamentally we're going to evaluate
your work based on the appropriateness
of your metrics the strength of your
methods and the extent to which the
paper is open and clear-sighted about
the limitations of its findings that
really reflects our values this does
mean that if your paper reports top
results on some leaderboard but has
chosen strange metrics and feels
unmotivated you will not necessarily do
well on the final paper
and conversely and this is more
important if you tried something really
creative and ambitious and it didn't pan
out in terms of results on some
leaderboard that matters hardly at all
you might have a really informative
negative result on your hand and the
whole scientific Community would benefit
from seeing it so there we're going to
look to the strength of your methods and
the evidence that you've got and that
will carry the day
papers for this course have a few
special sections that come at the end I
thought I would just review those and
talk in particular about the motivations
let's start with the known project
limitations section The Prompt here
imagine that your reader is a
well-intentioned NLP practitioner who is
seeking to make use of your data models
or findings as part of a separate
scholarly's project deployed system or
some other kind of real world
intervention have that person in mind
and ask what should such a person know
about your work
things you might think about benefits
and risks of the work cost to your
participants to society to the planet
and so forth
responsible use of your data models and
findings
you might be able to think of other
things that should fall under this
heading I want to emphasize that I have
asked you to have in mind a
well-intentioned NLP practitioner I
think it's very hard to think through
how to reach someone who's going to be a
bad actor and try to apply your ideas
for evil purposes or use them in some
problematic way set that kind of thing
aside and just focused on the person who
is trying to build productively on your
ideas to do something good in the world
that person might have the best
intentions but not really appreciate
where the limitations of your ideas lie
this is an opportunity to communicate
directly with that person about the
limitations and in doing that I think
you could save them a lot of grief you
could save their users a lot of grief
and ultimately this seems like a really
important thing for us to be doing in
this era when our research can have such
wide-ranging impacts
in the spirit if you get really into
this you could think about doing things
like data sheets model cards and impact
statements these are more extensive
structured documents that again help you
with disclosures mainly to
well-intentioned users I didn't insist
on them for this coursework because it
is a lot of work but if you think about
releasing data and models out into the
wider world I think it would be great to
confront all the issues that these kind
of structured documents ask you to
confront
we also require an authorship statement
and again this is about our scientific
perspective it is not about evaluation
fundamentally this statement should
explain how the individual authors
contributed to the project
you can include whatever information you
deem important to convey
if you would like some examples I
recommend this document here which is
publication guidelines for pnas it
includes some tips on good authorship
statements
the rationale again is scientific we
think this is an important aspect of
scholarship in general especially in
this era when we have large team papers
this is not about evaluation and it is
not meant to be punitive only in extreme
cases and after discussion with the
entire team would we consider giving
separate grades to team members based on
this statement it's not about grading
this is about how we publish and how we
take credit for our ideas and how we
explain the contributions of individual
scientists